now a four is the philosophy of life
we're gonna get through that but we have
to go back to the beginning where this
thing started to get to a really
understanding of what life is really
about
when we come into this world we come
into this world believe in what someone
else tells us cuz we babies a woman wake
up and say I'm your mother I'm your
father
you really don't know that you just
gonna like what they tell you so as you
grow if you have many children like if
you got three or four kids and you got a
younger one first mom and dad telling
you what to do then your brothers and
sisters babysit you and give you and
tell you what to do and you have to
remember all these people character is
different when they grow so with mom and
dad tells you and your brother tells you
and your sister your older sister tells
you might be a little different when
with mom and dancer because they don't
seem they eyes been open they done grew
and they haven't seen things differently
from what mom said and with that said
they outlook on life then you go to your
school teacher then you go to your boss
and he tells you what we need to do this
for the job and this is the way I want
things did you might have experience in
the job and say when I worked for coming
in and we did any but I'm the boss it's
got to go my way
you do it this way now you don't work
here so by the time you do it like that
and you've worked him for 20 or 30 years
he got part of his character installed
in you you know and so then you come up
wanting things you see the bicycle and
the only thing that makes you want it
and did you see Jimmy with that
brand-new bicycle I want one of them oh
look look at those new George and you
got a pair of Jordans on your feet but
you want the ones that look different
I want to pair them so as we go through
life we study wanting these things then
you want to drive lights in the car I'm
not saying this is wrong if you could
just sustain these kind of things and
you don't mind stirring every day like
babies
you got to head up keep on them so any
kind of anguish we in our lives we call
then on ourselves by wanting so much now
you take a guy
I'm not saying them better I'm homeless
right out here like everybody else but
you take a guy like me I've never had a
drink of liquor in my life never had a
crack fight never did Cristal never had
a driving license
never had a phone never went to school
never had a really house no brothers no
sisters no wife and kid so a guy like
that he comes up living life on life
terms
and then there's he he might have wanted
these things cuz he's human and we all
want these things but once you
determined in your mind that you cannot
live without them a life is no good
without them then this is will start
coming depression suicidal your wife
left you and you got child support you
know now you listening to your home
while you're going to bar and you start
drinking and you have a drink and it is
it takes you away from the reality of
life and then you do usually start doing
your drugs you start on your drug run
and all these things take you from
reality of life but only one thing the
old sin what goes up must come down so
when you get sober or when you come off
that drug the same problem exists but
now you couldn't fix it then and you
don't and you can't fix it now when you
keep doing it till you listen to all
your friends giving you advice and then
by the time you get 60 or 70 years old
you say Who am I what is it that I
really wanted to do because I did what
my mama wanted me to do I did my dad
wanted me to do I did my brothers wanted
me to do I did when my school teacher
told me to do I did what my boss told me
to do and then he came to my wife and my
kids I had to live to please them oh I
don't like this and I don't like that
the problem with wives and kids is is
that even if you're married and you
become one
you really are four because you have to
live for your wife meet her demands and
keep her happy but you have a card you
said what character of your own on the
way you feel and the way you
new things and this is where arguments
and fights start well I didn't know you
were like that I told you did when we
got married I didn't like that well I
you want me to change my whole life to
love you well see this is what love is
about love is something so powerful and
so beautiful that if you try to control
it or understand it just like it makes
you feel good it'll make you feel bad
because I'm not real religious fanatic
but if there is a God how can you
understand the power that God created
you know so you like wouldn't around
with love is as most people be so busy
trying to understand it and control it
they never even settled down to truly
love each other you hear women say well
why do you love me so much oh man why do
you love me so much why does there have
to be a reason for instance me and you
met I don't even I don't really know you
and you really don't know me you know
what I told you but when we get around
each other we we comfortable and we
smile with each other like we've been
knowing each other all our lives and we
got people we've been knowing each other
our lives get worried I'm sure on both
sides that we don't care to be around we
have met people we don't care to have
them around us where you'll meet
somebody you met a week ago and you hit
it off with him good and you like this
person you don't mind being around them
and he's a good he got a good deal she
got a good disposition about this well
they know how to smile they not
stressful and they don't have a lot of
hang-ups in life now we are human so I
fall sometime in the category to where
we lose things and we gain things
everything gonna come and go in life
you're not gonna have anything forever
the only things you will have this you
have to buy more did you want to make a
payment on your clothes and your food
everything else if you get a phone you
got to make that payment every month if
you get a car you got to make that
payment every month about his gas and so
on and I'm not saying that's wrong
that's good cuz toys and nice things in
life is the human way but the problem is
is when you decide you can't have that
or make that payment you know your life
is not over and most people think life
is over like if you see a person burn
Oh house burned down my house burned
down I lose everything
but you didn't lose your life what have
you two been in that fire and lost your
life so you can get all this again see
but you can't get your life back again
you know and so my thing is this here I
used to listen to three song now I
listen to five songs and I always walk
around sing these songs and they do one
song I always say maybe don't worry
cause every little thing gonna be all
right
and then the first song now they should
love it say uh and got nowhere to live
your wife then bro got change I said
your wife done left you you're broke but
don't worry be happy you know and then
they had two songs to come out about
your a about a few months ago the one
that says everybody ain't my partner
everybody ain't my friend and we all see
people pop up in the skid Road and they
don't even know each other they'll walk
around Skid Row for one month or two
months and say what's up og what's up
one love and this I calls them on it and
most people don't and then they're
wonder why your backpack could get
stolen off everything is stolen because
you let a guy or a female or male show
up and walk around for a month and you
swear to god you know him because they
start saying what's up one level of OD
but you didn't know this person and you
allow this person to lay next to you
hang out with you and then when you woke
up all your stuff was gone there's an
and then you were or why did he do that
because you did not know him I heard and
it was a setup
I'm gonna be from the gate a con artist
is the most vicious rattlesnake it is
because his he or his dog he or her or
his job is to lower you in to make you
feel comfortable I mean look at you a
big guy I'm a rough looking dude but do
you I don't have a tattoo I've never
carried a gun I carried a weapon never
did I rob Chile but when most people
look at me they think I'm a rough guy
bank robber killer molester drug seller
drug user and I've never done none of
that
and then the guys that don't look as
rough as me they think oh he's a nice
guy you know and this is the guy that's
got you for everything you took you want
it see because my thing if there is a
good and evil if the devil wanted to get
your soul he's not gonna send some big
guy like you with all these muscles
somebody you'll be nervous let's get up
he gonna send a sweet little old lady a
little girl you can get to mess it comes
yeah that's a guards down like did you
uh I don't know this movie you ever saw
this movie where I think it was
something about it might have been uh
the walking dead or something right and
then had this little girl in their
little blonde girl
and she was so cute and sweet and she
set up and smiled a guy and she they had
no signs of being one of the walking
dead and she was just as beautiful as
she wanted to put it and the guy walked
up to and say honey
are you all right and I'm out oh I
turned into a vicious monster and bit
him when he had got away one of the main
vitals hue I got away from all got a
load in by the pretty little girl
because they couldn't get him then he
was a good fighter and he saw me knew
him he was whooping a lot of maybe it'd
be 10 20 of them coming at him and he'd
whip them all but this little girl this
little pretty sweet innocent girl I made
him smile say honey and he picked them
and show you all right and when he put
her right here she turned into a monster
and bit the hell out of him
so my point is when people stressed out
in life they always like to point the
finger well you did this me I couldn't
make my girl play because of you and so
you blame them for making not making
your car payment when what is huge and
made the final decision when they say
because you loaned me that hundred fifty
dollars of him I'll have it back by the
time your car payment due but when it
wasn't there
you want to blame it but they didn't put
a gun to your head and make you do it
see and you don't never wait for the
outcome and listen to the whole story
and you have to look into
for you're dealing with and so the
philosophy of life is this my friend if
you go through life wanting everything
everything you see your commercial
society is not their fault it's the
business they are big to advertise stuff
on the TV and you say I want it and you
say I want to do this I want babies
probably most people want that American
Dream they want the white picket fence
the house the family the car and they
want to be able to go out to the clubs
and have the nice little drinks the 10
and 20 dollar drinks and live on Beverly
Hills whether it's a nightclub and the
ghetto you want to show it up when the
homies I got I got the new Stacy's own
make I'm driving a convertible BMW and
all the little girls waving they little
dresses showing you little bus winning
and you just eatin it up and every time
you see something most people want to
body a George before they take care of
their kids
most people want to make that car
pavement before they get we give they
woman fire guy have $1,900 here give us
girl he has spoiled $1.00 gold and buy
something go get yourself something nice
and actually one of my buddies when I
said you ever been in Victoria's Secret
have you ever been in bath and Bodyworks
one bottle of lotion that cost you $25
you got $1,900 but you will only give
your wife 30 or 40 of our hundred
dollars of it but you want to go home
and jump up and down in and have all
these glorious lovely sex when she get
drunk and all that you don't want to
make your payments and nothing like you
want to make your car payment things you
think it makes you look good for society
peer pressure
oh I got to knew why I got the new Audi
look at my Volvo convertible you don't
want to Chevy no motor you want the
convertible Mercedes now you won't
devolve on the Audi you want the Nissan
Ford is not good enough for you you want
that beautiful new brand new BMW they
just brought out the little sports when
they got nice little sports BMW
oh look like a Ferrari or something and
I look at this thing another day I
thought wouldn't that about three
hundred thousand hundred fifty thousand
dollar
Carr and my buddies here I'm gonna get
me one and I looked at my say you are
what's wrong with the car you got oh I
want that new BM good like Ferrari and
you got the money for that living in
Skid Row huh
well yeah I got the money for what I'm
saying what about your children and your
car payment your house and all that you
got that kind of a job well no big up in
the slang some of this dope and I say
you gonna let you take the government
gonna let you slang that dope but not
actually we were no receipts and what
you gonna do try to put in somebody
else's name and see the government came
up with something on that one two people
would sell a lot of drugs and put oh I
put it in your name and then they will
go to the sister and mother and say well
this is you you bought him this and
that's your car then this is your house
can we see your receipts because if we
catch new line we gonna take everything
from you too and so now you don't got
your family in trouble trying to
undercut the government but you can't
undercut the government because it's not
about the government
it's about society haven't been a may be
living in a function able world and
everybody's not gonna be rich it takes
all sides of life to make a world
I don't drink nothing but I'm homeless
here never had a day of school but to
hear me speak sometime I have had people
say you don't have no phone you don't go
to library you don't read the book you
don't know you have no books you walk
around and Skid Row never went to school
but we hear you speak will you get this
kind of knowledge fun because I traveled
living in different cultures and I paid
attention to life see we don't pay
attention to things around us so what
I'm saying is that when people say they
rich they want to be rich
I say how you know you're not rich
because you're not rich in Cannes I mean
listen to the way I speak like I say
there's no explanation for that I don't
read books I don't care as phones and
stuff and so people say will you get
that knowledge that I say cuz I'm rich
you rich in what I'm rich in knowledge
look at the man that's got the 50
million but he got a pace to make in his
heart yeah I'm saying so look at me and
you you up in age you little bit too but
when I pull my shirt off we
got bodies like we've been working out
all our lives yeah I'm saying and we and
where did you not say well he shot you
getting on saying whatever explanation
could it be everybody never went to
school and you think it's somebody up
there maybe it's a god put it in me
maybe this is my richness of Richard
knowledge and an understanding of life
and to only understand in life all
you've got to do is live because all we
gonna do is live on this planet and we
can't take anything with us you can't
put that BMW in that gadget and take it
with you and even now even now we don't
learn from the past history looking over
history even kids sit up and wonder when
their parents gonna die when they get
when they get a big wheel in them
sometimes you walk through the house not
you personally but you see your daughter
or your son sitting there staring at you
and you say uh what are you looking at
why are you staring at me like that and
all when I said that I was just thinking
about something dad but in their mind
they saying they looking at you like dad
left me ten million dollars and that
will be healthy he ain't gonna die soon
at all that man running around playing
basketball and running all over the
world moms healthy so the Menendez
brothers they want that money fast
kill the parents they didn't say well
their abusers okay that might be true
but they not even tell us that now you
killed them before they could tell us
that of what we could investigate that
and they talked the first child they
were gonna date it was a mistrial you
know he's gonna get out oh we got a
mistrial
and of course say okay they come they
said okay you got all that money and you
got a mistrial give him another trial
and take it all and now they got all the
money and then when they're dead
brothers in prison because you cannot
capitalize on a crime look at Nicole's
sister n'ajjer and OJ Simpson look at
that guy he's played Robert Blake
forever and his wife had him on trial
because it take any murders well I'm
gonna be able to beat that one or not I
didn't find an outcome on that one then
but we had him on trial for trying to
kill it right so money and these have
been a root of all evil because most
people when you're a baby you
once you grow your knowledge becomes now
you're looking and you're gonna learn
now that smile and turn into a snake
smile yes hey how you doing man all
right but they lookin cuz they won't now
they want that new that new car now they
want that big-ass house now they want to
sit up in Beverly Hills and drink coffee
on sunset way out on sunset with the
Stars because you got a decent job but
you're really not a star but you want to
hang among those people who kind of
trying to make you come up like the
billboard on sunset where Wilt
Chamberlain used to go there and have
all sex with all these different women
now he's dead
see and a lot of people saying how would
you know about the billboard on sunset
how would you know about all the coffee
shops the way up there lunch they would
enrich me cuz I have went there through
there to see that now but when I was in
Miami Florida Miami Dade they got some
of the most beautiful beaches in the
world
and and the sand is so snow white you
can see your feet in the water but the
people in this beautiful city is certain
is so they not in this and they differ
mentally the people in Miami also also
are naive to a lot of things were so
ignorant to a lot of things to all they
do is rob steal and kill them that's all
they do
rob stealing here we're here all they do
a lot of robbing anybody died down but
all they do is sell drugs here it's just
the only thing they know how to do
anyway and when we look at it and they
say or why did you do that cuz that's
the only thing I really know how to do
and if you do not to do something you're
gonna became so comfortable with doing
this that you don't even want to
enlighten yourself to try to do anything
else cuz you're late you want to stand
out to sell dope not going out there
watching cause they're going out there
going to work every day sitting in the
office feeling pain all ain't good
enough for me I want to be out there
selling dope looking at the fact but
girls and and looking at all the dues
and life is not cut up like that this
world has to function whether we like it
or not then we can't point the fingers
say I can't point
Oh [ __ ] jokbal ain't got no brothers
and sisters it's your fault I ain't got
no wife and kid sometimes you have to
say this is just the way life is cuz
like I said I'm no better than anyone
else I'm homeless right here in Skid Row
sleep on the street and mostly backs me
why Mama's because I don't do all the
above
well people uh I probably could have
went further in life but I did I will
not make an excuse I chose to be here
because I felt like if I had did
anything else I would have stretched out
like the rest of people wouldn't have
any kind of feelings are caring for the
people I would have been caught up in
material stuff and not care what anyone
else went through and sometime I'm a
little hard on people because I think
they're a little lazy or they just ruled
but basically I try to keep a good
attitude with a good understanding of
life and I'm not the thug or the real
mean honorable person that most people
look at I don't know how I got that look
but I do have that look but I have never
ever carried weapons or better than
anything like that until then I hope
everybody have a good life and remember
love material things but don't get
caught up in it where it will control
your life because everything goes and
come and clean your life have a good day
people
you